[Music]
on march 5th
jennifer katrin of fredericksburg
virginia walks up the gangplank to the
cruise ship coastal luminosa
operated by costa cruises and owned by
carnival corporation
oh my gosh she's documenting her first
solo trip without her husband or
children we're gonna go exploring the
ships
the ship was scheduled to leave fort
lauderdale that evening sail south
through the caribbean
and east across the atlantic but by this
point
the new coronavirus was already
spreading in countries outside of
china including an outbreak in february
on the diamond princess
also owned by carnival more than 700
people on that ship had been infected
and seven had died according to the
world health organization
carnival kept cruising
over the two weeks jennifer spent on the
coast illuminosa
she recorded more than 100 separate
videos of herself and her fellow
passengers
jennifer's videos offer a look at life
on board the ship
the coastal luminosa like the diamond
princess before it became a floating
incubator
putting passengers and crew at risk and
helping to spread the virus around the
world
carnival said that covet 19 has spread
rapidly throughout communities
and cruise ships are literally
microcosms of what is occurring in major
population centers
the story of the coastal luminosa begins
on february 29th
an italian passenger is taken off the
ship in the cayman islands into a local
hospital
he's suffering from double pneumonia and
has had a heart attack according to
subsequent interviews with his son
the luminosa then heads south to
mahogany bay honduras
it turns north to cozumel mexico then it
heads east
to port in fort lauderdale florida
where it will pick up more passengers
including jennifer
so far i think it's gonna be great you
know when i first boarded and i started
walking around
i thought oh my gosh i'm going to get so
bored i got my itinerary for tomorrow
and i completely changed my mind
the coastal luminosa departs fort
lauderdale on the evening of march
5th and sails south along the bahamas
it arrives in the port of san juan
puerto rico on march 8th
hundreds of passengers disembark
jennifer heads to the old city
so beautiful
incredible absolutely incredible people
here are friendly
there's already people in the bars and
restaurants
jennifer returns to the ship an
ambulance picks up an italian passenger
in respiratory distress
and takes her to a local hospital a
coast guard spokesman says the luminosa
didn't tell authorities about
illnesses aboard the ship while it was
docked carnival
said it was acceptable to notify them
after the fact
in view of the emergency nature of the
passenger transfer
the coast guard is investigating
the ship leaves puerto rico and set sail
for st john's antigua on the evening of
march 8th
they arrive the following day but are
denied entry
the government said the luminosa did not
inform them in a timely fashion
that there had been a passenger on board
with symptoms of an infectious disease
carnival said that the luminosa followed
the required regulatory protocol
the coastal luminosa then turns east and
heads out into the open ocean
staff members are cleaning a lot more
they're doing surfaces
people are still serving themselves in
the buffet
and people are still congregating and
activities are still going on on board
right now there's not a whole lot left
as you can hear there's still coughing
in the background
the ship heads into the middle of the
atlantic ocean group activities keep up
much as they had before
people congregate in restaurants and
bars
okay so here's life on the ship after we
just found out that there are no
ports in spain that are willing to take
us
we don't know where we're going to
refuel people are still
milling around this is friday the 13th
march 13th
2020 guys and we are on a boat
with no place to go
[Music]
i am seeing this situation deteriorate
hour by hour we're not quite at a
minute-by-minute
deterioration at this point the party
continues
in the early morning hours on saturday
the 14th
passengers gather for a sing-along
jennifer discovers some bad news found
an article online saying that the lady
in san juan was positive
it's actually getting pretty real
late that night the ship confirms the
couple dropped off in san juan have
coronavirus
two of the island's first three cases
according to the governor
by march 15th more bad news jennifer has
learned that the italian passenger who
disembarked in the cayman islands in
late february
has died with kovid 19.
the coastal luminosa is docked in the
port of santa cruz de tenerife in
spain's canary islands
the passengers are not allowed to
disembark
ladies and gentlemen may i have your
attention please
they just don't want anybody getting off
they don't want anybody jumping [ __ ]
three sick passengers in their travel
companions leave the ship to seek
medical care
on the evening of the 15th the ship
announces that passengers are to return
to their rooms
by the morning of march 16th all
restaurants are closed
may have your attention please in
regards to the passengers who
disembarked in tenerife we have no
further updates on their condition
and again we will update you as soon as
possible
last night i woke up at two o'clock and
i thought it was 2pm
i have no windows in here there's
nothing it's
literally the size of a closet the bed
takes up the entire
room i'm having a hard time
allaying my doubts and my fears to try
and trust the people that are in charge
it is march 19th and the coastal
luminosa arrives at the port of
the french government has given the ship
permission to dock
please strictly follow our instructions
that you have received regarding your
disembarkation
our teams are working around the clock
in a situation which is evolving very
rapidly
the french government has given the ship
permission to dock and more than 700
passengers prepare to disembark
italian passengers remain on board until
the ship reaches its final destination
in italy jennifer and others wait for
hours in buses on the dock
multiple passengers report there is
little or nothing to eat
after nightfall they are escorted by
police cars to the airport to catch a
plane
chartered to take them to atlanta
the plane takes off after midnight
several passengers interviewed by the
journal witness others collapsing
though it's not clear if it's from
illness or exhaustion
jennifer helps tend to the sick the
plane lands in atlanta
early on the morning of march 20th
passengers without fevers are allowed to
walk into the airport into connecting
flights
jennifer collapses in the airport she
gets to a hotel to quarantine
so i ended up in the emergency room last
night
or yesterday morning after at the
airport i guess the doctor said it was
just pure exhaustion
from not having slept or from not having
food for so long so hopefully we'll go
home
soon jennifer catrin returned home on
april 1st
she was never tested for coronavirus
she's since joined
a class-action lawsuit against costa
cruises
carnival says it cannot confirm how many
people on board the luminosa
have since died with covet 19.
the passengers have been crowdsourcing
their own unofficial tally through a
facebook group
so far they've counted 15 dead